[Musik]
Russen und Russinnen die Putin scharf
kritisieren so wie Igor haraschiersev
sie sind weniger aber es gibt sie nicht
im Exil auch nicht im Straflager sondern
mitten in der Gesellschaft
das ist meine Heimat und hier sind wir
auch schon bei dem Problem Heimat und
macht ich kenne den Unterschied ich
verstehe dass ich Russe bin ich mag mein
Land aber das Regime von Putin
respektiere ich nicht mag ich nicht ich
habe ihn noch nie gewählt
um in Kontakt mit diesen Menschen zu
treten wühle ich mich durch die sozialen
Medien schreibe zahlreiche Nachrichten
Frage sämtliche Kontakte wie er
Messenger-Dienste an das Ergebnis viele
Absagen drei
ist einer von ihnen er will ausdrücklich
sein Gesicht zeigen angst habe er keine
er verstoße auch nicht gegen das
Strafrecht seit 20 Jahren arbeitet er
als Journalist
ein echter Journalist sollte immer
oppositionell zur amtierenden
Staatsmacht sein ein Journalist sollte
sich für Demokratie engagieren und
keiner Partei zugehörig sein daran halte
ich mich
[Musik]
oppositionell zur Staatsmacht damit lebt
der 48-Jährige gefährlich in Russland
dies sind seine Bilder er hat ihn
gedreht den Aufstand der wagnergruppe
vergangenes Wochenende von Anfang an
mitten in Roßdorf am Don dort wo die
Söldnertruppen und ihr Anführer brigoshi
mit Jubel und Handykameras begrüßt
wurden
Überraschung war grenzenlos es war sogar
eine Art verblüfung denn ich habe weder
Polizei noch Geheimdienste in Rostow
sehen können
es gab nur Verkehrspolizisten die nicht
wussten was sie tun sollen
zu nah darf man den Soldat nicht kommen
trotzdem hunderte Bürger strömen auf die
Straßen bringen Wasser und Essen erzählt
Igor versorgen also diejenigen die einen
bewaffneten Aufstand im eigenen Land
ausführen sollen es wirkt skurril absurd
fröhlich
heraus dass man nicht Angst vor
russischen Atomwaffen haben sollte
sondern Vorbild gewordenen Menschen mit
Panzern die mit ihren Kolonnen
wollen
an diesem Samstag haben wir alle die
Machtlosigkeit erlebt
doch die breite Mehrheit würde nicht
verstehen wie ernst die Lage ist so Igor
besonders mit Blick auf die Ukraine zu
stark der Einfluss russischer Medien zu
schwierig der Zugang zu unabhängigen
Quellen
sie interessieren sich nicht für Politik
ja unsere Leute sind warmherzig sie
helfen auch den Flüchtlingen aber sie
haben keine Ahnung über die reale Lage
an der Front dieser sogenannten
spezialoperation die Menschen haben eine
Haltung der Ignoranz und wenn Sie sich
in diesem Ignoranten Zustand befinden
dann ist jeder Karneval wie in prigoren
jetzt veranstaltet hat für sie eine Show
für Berliner ist das keine Show sie hat
Angst zu reden Angst um ihre Familie
Angst vor Repressionen wir machen sie
unkenntlich geben ihr einen anderen
Namen eine andere Stimme denn sie will
sprechen seit dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine lässt sie das schlechte Gewissen
nicht mehr los
[Musik]
für mich ist das eine große Katastrophe
in erster Linie deswegen weil ich meine
Heimat verloren habe für mich ist der 24
Februar letzten Jahres der Zerfall von
allen Illusionen gewesen ich habe nicht
verstanden in was für einem Land ich
eigentlich lebe
die meisten in der russischen
Gesellschaft seien zu abgestumpft um zu
verstehen was Putin gerade anrichtet
[Musik]
ich denke dass es in Russland jetzt drei
Gruppen gibt in die die ganze
Bevölkerung unterteilt werden kann die
erste Gruppe ist die größte diesen
Menschen ist alles egal hauptsache die
Preise steigen nicht so stark das sind
solche Ignoranten denen es nur darum
geht selbst nicht betroffen zu sein
die zweite Gruppe bestehen aus treuen
putin-anhängern Galina zählt sich zu
Gruppe 3
[Musik]
und es gibt eine kleinere Anzahl in der
Bevölkerung die versteht das Russland am
Rande einer riesigen Katastrophe steht
denn solche Sachen bleiben nicht
ungestraft
[Musik]
im großen Ganzen hat Russland sich
selbst den Krieg erklärt
lukaine bleibt bestehen denn die ganze
Welt steht jetzt der Ukraine bei und
Gott ist an ihrer Seite die Ukraine hat
eine helle und sehr gute Zukunft
vielleicht nicht sofort und mit vielen
Opfern und Hindernissen aber über
Russland kann ich das nicht sagen
auch sascha hat Zweifel an einer guten
Zukunft für Russland meine Kollegin
Anastasia tiramirova erreicht den
24-Jährigen via Videocall seine
Identität bleibt geheim
hat gezeigt dass noch schlimmere Leute
als Putin an die Macht kommen könnten
Militärs an der Macht zu haben wäre noch
schlimmer
wir haben natürlich bereits eine
militarisierte Gesellschaft
aber der Gedanke daran dass Typen an die
Macht kommen könnten die frisch von der
Front kommen und dort Leute gefoltert
und umgebracht haben das wäre noch
schlimmer
setzt sich ein für ein demokratisch
sozialistisches Russland und ist
überzeugt Putins macht bröckelt nicht
erst seit ein paar Tagen
für alle die Putin nicht leiden konnten
hat die Diskussion über den Anfang
seines Endes schon im Februar 2022
begonnen
das was jetzt am Wochenende passiert ist
ist er als eine Episode dieses Endes zu
sehen aber für viele Leute die sich als
z-patrioten verstehen und sowohl Putin
als auch Wagner unterstützt haben hat
sich vermutlich etwas verändert sie
müssen jetzt eine Seite wählen
früher konntest du für Putin und Wagner
sein jetzt musst du dich entscheiden für
wen du bist und anscheinend bleiben
nicht alle hinter Putin stehen einige
haben entschieden dass sie die Regierung
nicht mehr so stark Vertrauen
der geschwächte der wankende angegriffen
von seinem eigens gezüchteten Jagdhund
der provozierte gramme-chef werde
vermutlich härter gegen seine Feinde
Vorgehen das sind Oppositionelle wie
Sascha bereits gewohnt
es ist unwahrscheinlich dass sich diese
Situation für die linke und liberale
Opposition verschlechtert im Prinzip
wurden wir schon vorher mit Repressionen
überzogen und in Haft gefoltert
der linke Aktivist sieht in dem
wagneraufstand sogar eine Chance mehr
Menschen für die Seite der
oppositionellen zu gewinnen
[Musik]
Galina geht es nicht um Politik sie will
der Welt vor allem aber der Ukraine
zeigen dass Russland auch ein anderes
Gesicht hat deswegen kümmert sie sich um
ukrainische geflüchtete bittet um
Verzeihung Galina weiß das ist riskant
[Musik]
jetzt ist es für mich einerseits der
gefährlichste Ort andererseits ist es
für mich der größte Segen diesen
Menschen zu helfen sie zu umarmen und
mich zu entschuldigen
das einzige was wir jetzt machen können
ist zu beten damit Russland bereut was
es getan hat und damit aufhört
sie gibt sie nicht auf ihre Hoffnung auf
Frieden und Vergebung
Igor zieht wiederum ein ernüchterndes
Fazit
alle Herrscher die zum Imperialismus
Streben verlieren letztendlich den
Verstand
einerseits ist es schmerzhaft für mich
das zu beobachten andererseits macht das
alles jetzt Sinn und was soll ich sagen
ich bleibe trotzdem in Russland
sie alle drei bleiben in Russland eine
Ausreise könnten sie sich auch gar nicht
leisten und bleiben damit seltene
kritische Stimmen mitten in einem
autoritären Regime
[Musik]